taylor lorenz journalist of the new york
times has gotten some attention
recently for some claims that she's made
about the ways that online harassment
have impacted her so she tweeted this on
international women's day which
hopefully as you know a couple days ago
i hope that you commemorated and
celebrated it as
as i did she said for international
women's day please consider supporting
women enduring online harassment
it's not an exaggeration to say that the
harassment and smear campaign campaign
i've had to endure over the past year
has destroyed my life no one should have
to go through this it's not
it's not an exaggeration taylor are you
sure about that
i think it is it sounds like an
exaggeration to me she says i'm slightly
open about some of what i deal with but
the scope of attacks has been
unimaginable
there's no escape it's taken everything
from me
the only mild solace i've found with is
with other women
who have had their lives destroyed in
the same way we've developed deep
trauma bonds deep
trauma bonds um because by the way the
trauma bonds sounds like maybe like a
an indie band anyway i'll return to that
later
um trauma because of mean comments on
the internet
and this is what you so often get from
feminists especially
feminist journalists where they really
seem to believe this is not a put on
much of what they're doing here is much
of this is performative
but the part that's not performing is i
i think she really believes
that she is uniquely suffering this
or at least that women and especially
women journalists uniquely suffer this
kind of thing
it doesn't happen to the rest of us
certainly doesn't happen to men
men never have to endure any of this
no men anyone in the public eye
i'm not saying it's a good thing i have
no doubt that taylor lorenz gets a lot
of
really mean comments really vile
comments
i have no doubt about that i'm sure she
gets many
messages that are that may be quite
upsetting to her
i have no doubt now
i have no doubt because i get that kind
of stuff all the time myself
most of the time it's not upsetting to
me because i don't allow myself to be
upset
and that's really what it comes down to
it's it's a question of
how are you going to respond to this
what is your reaction going to be
because you're going to get it on the
internet
all you can decide is how you'll respond
if it really has destroyed your life i
don't even know how that could be the
case
if it is the case that it's destroyed
your life then why don't you simply get
off the internet
and uh go do something else for a living
now i wouldn't normally say that you
should do something else for a living
simply to avoid
mean comments on the internet but if
you're saying it's destroyed your life
and cause trauma and you can't get over
it and it's unimaginable there's no
escape
well there is this you know you know
what the escape is from from comments on
the internet
um the escape is this i'll show you
demonstration here's the escape watch
i'll show you
that's how you escape i'll show you
again if you're watching um so to escape
mean comments on the internet you do
this
put the phone down that's it and all of
that stuff it's happening here
and i can put it down and live my life
that's the great thing this has happened
many times where people are attacking me
on twitter and
all of this stuff and it's so great that
i can just
click off put it down go read a book to
my kids
doesn't matter let the internet freak
out doesn't matter to me
so there is an escape but it happens to
all of us um
if if there's an impression that it
doesn't happen to men
as often i think the reason is that we
don't talk about it as much
you know that has to be the reason
i i don't go around talking about it all
the time and talking about how to
destroy my life doesn't mean it doesn't
happen
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated